building the next great Android app
isn't enough you can have the most
amazing social integration best API
coverage and the coolest filters but
none of that matters if your app is slow
and frustrating to use and that's why
you'd a stating Google created the
Android performance course to help you
learn how to make fast smooth and
awesome experiences for users of course
we've used the performance pillars of
rendering compute memory and battery and
use the tools in Android studio to find
a fix performance problems by the end of
the course you'll understand how common
performance problems arise from your
hardware OS and application code and
using profiling tools to gather data
you'll identify and fix performance
bottlenecks so you just can have that
smooth 60 frames per second experience
that will keep them coming back for more
hashtag perf matters for more
information visit Udacity com forward
slash Google
you